is venture capital going to kill your
neighborhood convenience store
since the pandemic forced people into
lockdown new york london and berlin have
been flooded with rapid grocery services
like get here
gorillas and go puff they operate from
so-called dark stores
small warehouses and cheap locations
away from the high street
and promise to deliver a six-pack of
beer bag of doritos or a raw steak to
your front door
as little as 10 minutes after you order
from their app
but is this just another case of venture
capitalists putting billions into
businesses that are never going to turn
a meaningful profit
charles thorne an equity analyst with
jefferies took an innovative approach to
finding out
he's previously worked as a courier for
ubereats and deliveroo to get a sense of
how their businesses worked
this time he and his team set up camp
outside a getty a dark store in london
and set about counting how many orders
it got the idea was if you turned up at
a dark store because
all orders are being fulfilled from a
single spot
you just need to go to that spot and
count the number of people
on bikes cycling out with backpacks on
to have a pretty good idea that that was
a proxy for an order
and if you spend enough time if you
spend a day if you spent a week
you can actually build a pretty robust
view of what the daily order count was
and getty was getting a lot more orders
than he expected just six months after
opening the store was averaging 340
orders per day
depending on the size of each order each
store could therefore conservatively be
making between four million and six
million dollars a year in revenue he
estimates
that could be even more if basket sizes
are bigger we know from some of the
commentary out of the
private operators the pure play dinosaur
private operators that basket sizes are
comfortably north of 20 euros and
trending towards 30 euros
that let him estimate that an
established dark store can make an
operating profit that represents between
percent and ten percent of sales that
compares favorably with convenience
stores which typically enjoy a profit
margin of between two percent and four
percent
the model can be more profitable because
it has some lower costs
it doesn't need premium real estate
locations to attract the passing
customer so rent is cheaper
and each store can cover quite a wide
area of around 11 square kilometers so
you need fewer locations
but setting up does require a lot of
money at least 1.4 million dollars per
store according to thorn
the last generation of rapid growth
consumer investments were platforms
three-sided marketplaces like uber lyft
or airbnb
that connected a customer with someone
offering a product or service
and took a percentage cup in theory it's
a business model that doesn't require
much
investment because you're acting as
little more than a catalyst
but in reality the low barriers to entry
have made competition
tough and marketing costs high if you're
a dark grocery operator
you're really only competing for the
customer if your ubereats or deliveroo
you're competing on three fronts for the
customer for the best restaurants and
for couriers all of whom might find a
better deal with one of your rivals
the initial outlay for dark stores is
higher but once it's up and running it
should be more efficient
firstly these companies are burning
money on marketing to attract new
customers
that's fine for now they've raised three
billion dollars from investors this year
alone
as venture capitalists determined that
the pandemic induced lockdowns were
accelerating e-commerce trends
but it's clearly not sustainable for a
city like london to have a dozen
different ultra-fast delivery companies
at some stage some will go under
or be acquired by their rivals finally
and perhaps most significantly
will the growth trend survive the
lockdowns when people are working from
home they can place dark store orders
throughout the day
but if they return to the office and
orders become concentrated in the
evenings
the business case may not add up as
readily besides it's easier for
commuters to pop into the corner store
on their way home
it's pretty clear however the dark
stores are here to stay the irony is
that if everyone decides it's an
attractive business supermarkets and
venture capitalists alike
will continue to pile into the space and
the ensuing price war will mean it
ceases to be an attractive business
it'll be good for the consumer but your
local bodega might find that its lunch
is being eaten by someone else
this is alex webb for bloomberg quick
take in london
you